racolage beaucoup plus discret les sites
se multiplient depuis deux ou trois ans
en quête frédéric protat patrick voix en
plein centre ville
une entreprise qui ne connaît pas la
crise une quinzaine de salariés certains
en contrat à durée indéterminée le
studio n'a rien d'hollywoodien le fonds
de commerce ici c'est le x1 ambroisie un
endroit canapé plus salon en fait les
actrices peut faire leur intervention en
direct soit chez elle soit des studios à
sedan qui lui prévenir les actrices
devant une caméra des milliers de
connexions au chaque jour ici
l'internaute peut tout trouver de la
vidéo coquine à la porno réalité on
atteint les 80 mille euros par mois de
chiffre d'affaires en abonnement on
pense qu'on va le doublé dans les deux
ans à venir où on est dans une mode de
téléchargement de deux films bien précis
qui sont demandées choses qui sont plus
compliquées à obtenir en allant dans un
sex-shop ou dans un magasin spécialisé
ça facilite le business effectivement
mais en même temps il faut être très
prudent car pour un site en règle avec
la loi combien d'autres qui servent de
façade à des réseaux de proxénétisme
ce site propose par exemple des rendez
vous avec des actrices de films pornos
cet autre est basé onglet lorsqu'on le
contact voici ce qui vous est proposé
entend on à détruire la paris yasmina
pour les proxénètes qui exploitent ces
sites c'est un moyen d'échapper aux loi
sur le racolage de plus en plus à une
prostitution qui que je fais qui est
plus volatile entre guillemets c'est à
dire qu'elle est moins visible par les
riverains mais qu'elle est offerte tout
un chacun sur internet qu'on a
maintenant plus en plus de jeunes femmes
qui ne se constituent plus physiquement
mais distribue des cartes
avec affichage des tarifs auto
mensurations puisque vous voulez pour
lutter contre ces réseaux une seule arme
une coopération internationale entre la
france et des pays où ces sites sont
fabriqués hébergés et parfois protégés